[Musique]
la rue Raymond meunier ça vous dit
quelque chose je la connais mais c'est
tout oui c'est une rue qui est située au
au bourg là donc qui est le nom d'une
ancienne résistante vous connaissez la
par particularité de cette ville pas du
tout elle détient le record de France de
noms qui portent des noms de femmes vous
en pensez quoi ben je trouve ça super et
c'est important pour vous de vivre dans
une ville qui porte tant de nom de femm
oui c'est primordial pour euh l'égalité
entre femmes et hommes moi je trouve que
c'est bien par rapport déjà au nom de la
ville la ville auam c'est
[Musique]
voilà bonjour à toutes et tous et
bienvenue à la ville au dame commune qui
détient le record de France de rue qui
porte des noms féminins aujourd'hui nous
sommes rue Raymonde
meunier depuis toujours la ville au
dames c'est une histoire de femme la rue
Raymonde meunier rend hommage à l'une
des plus résistantes dames du
coin Raymond Meier est né en 1906 à Joué
les Tours son mari Jean Meier fut
prisonnier dans les camps de l'armée
allemande à l'automne 40 il est libéré
mais Raymond décide déjà de s'engager
dans la résistance en 1942 avec son mari
elle intègre le réseau confrérie
Notre-Dame ça ne s'invente
pas en 1943 elle échappe de justesse aux
Allemands et elle se cache avec sa fille
à travers
[Musique]
l'indrloire c'est un bel hommage
d'offrir un nom de rue à une enfant du
pays qui a consacré sa vie à nos
[Musique]
libertés Chantal ciré est une passionnée
d'histoire qui publie des travaux de
recherche sur la résistance et sur la
Seconde Guerre mondiale en indr ir qui
de mieux pour parler de notre résistante
à nous Raymonde
Meier bonjour Chantal bonjour merci de
nous accueillir devant cette sale Maria
Calas résolument je vois que les femmes
sont partout à la ville au dame et
Raymonde Menier elle vous évoque quoi
alors Raymonde Menier c'est un exemple
de d'engagement pour moi parce que
d'abord elle était la fille d'un
syndicaliste cheminau qui a été licencié
après les grandes grves de 1920 donc
très jeune elle a touché du doigt ce que
représentait l'engagement et alors la
ville au dames cette commune qui met à
l'honneur les femmes dans ses rues dans
ses places vous en pensez quoi bah je
pense que c'est une excellente
initiative évidemment il faudrait
d'ailleurs qu'il y ait beaucoup plus de
rues en France qui portent le nom de de
femmes méritantes hein qui ont fait des
actions non seulement dans la résistance
mais un petit peu partout dans leur vie
c'est important pour vous ce travail de
droit et de devoir de mémoire pour moi
c'est un travail de mémoire je je n'aime
pas trop le terme de devoir de mémoire
je suis un peu comme Madame Simon veille
si je peux me permettre de me mettre à
un tout petit niveau par rapport à elle
d'ailleurs à chaque fois que je remets
des prix au concours au lauréat du
Concours national de la Résistance et de
la Déportation je leur rappelle bien
qu'ils ont exécuter un travail de
mémoire et non pas un devoir de mémoire
merci coup Chantal pour tout ce travail
de mémoire on voit qu'ici en indr et
Loire les femmes et l'engagement c'est
une histoire de cœur et de valeur et
d'ailleurs n'oubliez pas des fleurs des
cœurs des couleurs du bonheur même pas
[Musique]
peur